i want to ask you what it's like out
there because you've been doing stand-up
out
in the world and you know outdoors
i don't understand how that works how
did it go it is the worst
it's bad i don't care what any comics i
comment that's how comics tricked me
they got me going oh man
people are loving to be outside and
they don't care what you say man just
come on and i was like
uh all right and i went out there and
they was like
no no not good none of this is funny
not good crowd none of it no i had that
one crowd
i i left on a whole nother name that's
what i do anytime
anytime i'm horrible i'd be like i'm
trevor good night everybody
trevor sucks i can't do it man i just
i mean i try and then i tried again and
it got
better but one thing i can say if your
stuff work
in an outdoor audience it's gonna kill
inside
yeah so i just waited on those moments
that that that worked and
jotted them down and then that was it so
like two
two worked out of an hour you got two
moments out of it i got two good moments
out of an hour
you get two good moments out of an hour
you're not doing your job
hey you know but you've really been
discovering yourself over this sort of
pandemic quarantine period you've been
trying stuff you've never tried before
you're a dj now
well no i'm not i dj
but i'm not a dj but you are
getting like offers big offers and i
hear you're really good
and i've been going no cause i don't
want that kind of pressure on the
brother like that i can't be out here
carrying records and
and and letting down the people when i
can't blend the records right
you know because i blend a lot of disco
records in right
like those are real rhythm patterns this
ain't no beat machine that they was
doing it was a lot of cocaine
and it was they was off rhythm a lot you
know with a lot of them songs
yeah so to try to blend them songs in
together with the cocaine
it was just don't work it doesn't work
is this something though but you
started doing it for fun and then you
have friends
that are in the business and said hey
dion
uh dj for us yeah i had a friend i got a
friend named terry hunter he was like
man he was inspiring my other friend
named p1 and as
is all these djs was like you could do
this and i was like all right man i'm
gonna try and i did it and
i went from people going don't quit your
day job to
actual producers giving me their records
to to break and play
but i mean this could be a good sideline
doesn't mean you have to give up comedy
no but some of these djs get paid a
fortune
you go to vegas you get a fortune in a
weekend they get paid a lot of money and
like i said i've
i dj for a whole entire year from
in my house i never dj in front of
anybody until
mother's day i went to go see my mother
shout out to my mother hey charlene cove
i got to say her name charlene good to
see you yeah yeah so so i went and
and dj at a place where i actually only
played four songs
but that was the first time i ever did
it in front of people and i was
terrified
i wasn't even really blending the song
somebody had to come
move my hand over because i was i was so
like i was so scared people were like
blend the wreckage
i was that scared man but we had a good
time it was cool but that was my first
time
ever in front of anybody djing
this has got to be i mean you got to
keep going with this you got to bring me
in on it
why are you laughing i would blend right
in i'd be great i'd love to see you dj
a disco house party yeah yeah how do you
think that would go
next question
[Laughter]
i would love to see you and here's the
archie sugar sugar
crowd just tearing me apart literally
people
ripping my flesh off my bones people
going through yeah can i talk to you for
a second yeah yeah
and i'm up there going
to look over and just see a whole bunch
of this